miles de mujeres en francia se ven
obligadas a viajar al exterior cada año
para practicarse un aborto cuando
sobrepasan el plazo legal de 12 semanas
para algunos diputados franceses ampliar
el plazo a 14 semanas es crucial para
los derechos de las mujeres
mil 6.000 funky pastelito entre 3.000 y
5.000 mujeres viajan para abortar al
aborto no menguar yukos y deben uco si
dejo creo que el sistema sanitario ha
fallado y tenemos que remediarlo
urgentemente john dijo m 10
agotador recorrido del proyecto de ley
en el parlamento tuvo un comienzo
difícil hace dos años después de que la
asamblea nacional le diera luz verde en
su primera lectura pero fue rechazado en
el senado dominado por la derecha la
segunda lectura fue igual de conflictiva
cuando los republicanos propusieron una
avalancha de enmiendas que paralizaron
el proyecto de ley el pasado mes de
febrero el texto ha puesto de manifiesto
las grietas en el propio partido de
macrón aunque ha atraído el apoyo de
christophe castán el jefe de la
república en marcha en la asamblea
nacional
el presidente francés emmanuel macro ha
expresado sus reservas en una entrevista
concedida al periódico francés le figaro
en noviembre de 2021 el jefe de estado
afirmó su posición no he cambiado de
opinión los retrasos adicionales podrían
ser aún más traumáticos para las mujeres
los comentarios de macrón desataron la
indignación de los activistas pro
elección que argumentaron que echaba la
culpa a las mujeres a pesar de la
oposición del presidente carner ha
empezado la aprobación del proyecto de
ley en el parlamento la ley pondría a
francia a la altura de muchos de sus
vecinos en españa- se puede interrumpir
el embarazo hasta las 14 semanas en los
países bajos se puede abortar hasta las
22 semanas